Let's start out by talking
about assignments.
On the left you will generally
see the assignments tab.
This will bring you to a list of
assignments along with their due dates
throughout the course.
If you've changed a time zone in
your preferences now you will see
the due dates in your time zone.
To submit an individual assignment,
click on the assignment name.
Once you're in the assignment,
you'll see the due dates here,
the instructions here.
And then to submit the assignment,
you will type your answer here or
upload your submission here.
Then you will click Submit here.
So let me type in a quick response.
Now I will click Submit.
You should then receive
a Confirmation Screen
saying that your assignment has
been successfully submitted.
Now if I go back to
the Assignments List,
it will confirm that I have
submitted the assignment.
Now let's talk about how I will
receive my grade for the assignment.